and this is not me making this up the
driver was noted to have said if you
think that was fast watch this oh my God
that's kind of tight I'm happy
[Music]
I'm about to tell you a really sad story
four in a row I know
this one's gonna get you down more than
the suck rocks did
so try me there's a wedding in Australia
I don't know okay we have at this all
right is it injury heartbreak
expect Ed once you reach
a true level of sadness just raise your
hand okay okay by the end of this we'll
see who's really made of suck Rock
there's a wedding in Australia okay they
have this wedding kind of like in a wine
country area of Australia uh there's
about a hundred guests and you know when
you have uh a wedding that's a little
off the beaten path you take like a
chartered bus or something right and and
just shuttle everybody to the location
then you go back to wherever the parking
is right so there's about 35 of them
that get on a chartered bus leaving the
venue after the wedding's done like
they've done everything it was a
beautiful evening they get on the bus
um the driver of the bus ends up he's
going a little fast right I'm getting
sad now it's coming up
I'm anticipating it I know what's
happening as they approach uh what is a
roundabout area right oh no and this is
not me making this up the driver was
noted to have said if you think that was
fast watch this oh my God that's kind of
tight
[Laughter]
I'm not even kidding dude wait to watch
it there's a whole like there's a whole
diagram of him doing this [__] so this
bus driver is a real cool guy
like this dude is sick so he proceeds to
like take the roundabout at a really
fast speed and then he like bumps a curb
and the bus ends up rolling over
and it kills 10 guests in the crash okay
I'm sad yeah okay wow still okay good
you're still in there and then well we
and then another 25 people are hurt so
bad that some needed amputation
they had to bring in a crane to lift the
bus so they could get to the rest of the
bodies
bam so is he gonna be a school bus
driver now or what
MTA
[__] yeah it's horrifying so yeah he's
like the uh driver is now uh receiving
charges for his actions obviously was it
if they ever have a reunion for this
wedding everyone that shows up is going
to show like a World War II veteran oh
mothers are missing one's like oh you're
the guy from the weddings
this one's missing this one's [__]
missing this oh it has an eye patch
dude it's awful man if he was going too
fast and someone told him slow down and
he goes if you think that's fast check
this out I'm like
oh at that point you're gonna have to
kill him
like that's that if if someone said that
I'm like oh he's suicidal yeah I would
think about
pulling them off somehow right I think
it depends on his delivery though he's
like
hey guys you think that's fast or you
think that's fast oh that's true
actually girl right there what if what
if he usually does this and he's
actually really good most of the time he
might be then just one time just [__]
up just oil on the track yeah all I had
was a banana
yeah he might be here's a but is he uh
uh were people wearing their seat belts
that's mine yeah they were yeah they
were there were people wearing their
seatbelts so this is like they did it he
says it right there if you think this is
fast watch this if you think that's fine
because he's Australian right oh if you
think that's fast
whoa he's not oh yeah so he hits that
little car thing and then it goes over
yeah damn see and then the GTA theme
starts playing oh waste wait wait yeah
see that could have been easily
avoidable oh dude it like that it's
completely it's purely him being five
miles per hour in that the crazy thing
is like I've been on uh buses after
weddings on uh at like Big Sur where
they have to like navigate the Finesse
road on the oh [__] yeah and then those
guys are great like this guy was just a
flat Road or roundabout and he's being a
[__] yeah he's being yeah he's been
a little while talking dick
yeah it's just crazy to think that like
after something totally like [__]
[__] nice yeah you're gonna end up with
like just your lucky ended up with this
driver oh but uh mad [__] Max this
makes me never want to take a charter
bus ever again
this is just like a shuttle though what
if you go to Disneyland you got to take
shuttless see that's different right
because it's like you know it's like
okay they have to go 15 miles an hour
fast watch this and then they go
it turns around has a mask
Mickey Mouse
it's a nightmare
damn that's [__] crazy that's a good
Mickey dude
I saw this one um bus one that was
pretty [__] shocking it was on
Twitter because you know Twitter if you
could see crazier [__] right yeah so
it's like somewhere in Africa and so um
there's a Bus full of people and they're
Crossing this like flooded Road oh no
it's like a river yeah and then the bus
driver goes for it and then
it just sinks oh [__] it's doing like
Africa or something right and it takes
less than five seconds for that thing to
be submerged in a river holy [__] and
then people are just running just like
running right and then like you could
just see the bus sink and people are
like trying to climb out of the window
and it just goes down oh and it was like
what the [__] I bet that water's murky
too so yeah it's brown Water you're
getting the safe people like that you
can't even see holy [__] dude yeah what
do you think his quote was before he
went
you think we're not floating now
he's like trust me I've played the organ
Trail
yeah that was that was wild like how
quick it just went yeah I saw that video
and you saw it right sad yeah it's
really sad I'm like but you know what
what I don't like is didn't show like if
anyone got out it just shows this it
being submerged in people running after
and I'm like I think a lot of people
died in that oh yeah oh son of a beach
yeah because like you said it's like
there was a current yeah it wasn't just
like a lake it was like it was flood it
was not clear like that's the thing
about buses right like you don't know if
the guy behind the wheel is an absolute
[__] yeah like I want to be the [__]
driving not them at least I know I'd be
like that's a river I'm not gonna try
there's like 40 people in the back you
know yeah and it's not like everybody's
window was ready to go exactly because
they probably don't they're stupid maybe
some of them don't even go down like
this some people are probably sleeping
I mean this is another uh what is it
called level of idiot to the fact that
they know that he said that yeah yeah
prior like he's a hot shot about it he
probably watches like ice World truckers
in his life yeah what if he got away
with no injuries or nothing I think at
this point it would be fair to amputate
something all of them bro you gotta send
that guy to jail bro true don't you
think he is yeah amputate all of them
and rearrange it but the legs right here
[Laughter]
if you think that's weird
check out my job now
yeah terrible man it's it's very similar
to that uh remember that golf cart thing
that happened at the wedding night oh
this whole thing is like there was
someone was a they were like uh leaving
the ceremony in a golf cart and then a
car just careen's out of nowhere really
kills the kills the was it the bride and
yeah I think oh the bride oh my God that
Anthony was that no Anthony he he did a
good story yeah did that story if
Anthony was there yeah
Jesus
crazy [__]
freak accidents are crazy man yeah freak
accidents are crazy but and it's because
of one guy dude it's one dude yeah it's
one dude one guy that's the worst part
about it ten people died 10 fatalities
uh 25 injuries uh they still don't know
yet how many amputations because they're
all kind of in the process of recovering
and then um and then of the ten that
were killed some of them were
unretrievable until later Jesus you know
the Bank of America in downtown L.A yeah
it's like at the bottom uh Geo used to
work there oh that's the one she worked
at yeah she worked out that was one of
the ones she worked at and then some
dude uh crashed into it I think he fell
asleep at the wheel or whatever and just
plowed right through the the middle of
it and then like luckily no one got hurt
but like crazy [__] happens yeah yeah
falling asleep I think is a less you
know it's not that bad you know the fire
the fire truck crashed through the
dumpling shop right
yeah they were like answering a call and
then I think they hit a car or something
or they just drove right into the corner
shop and people were just [__] eating
their maybe they had to avoid somebody
huh and then while they were eating
[__] just boom and that's it can you
imagine just eating dumplings you know
when the next thing you know there's a
[__] fire truck blowing through you
and your Shadow about just pops in her
mouth
[Music]
foreign